DONALD TRUMP DID THIS.
>> IR.
NOTH
ND I WCLN  MTHPO
TUAORK ESAS AG VE
SD ERUTTRTH HTH IOUFUE  SASND
THFIEI IME UTERIDEYE
T,E IMS GEOM. D'TME T L QINPR HC
ED
ABE
TDE PE.
DYT GIG  GSAWE
W
VIREETON W
HNOCSIE E RHAS
NGCO
ST UAN J R>>
F ITHITIZ. ALI ENNT
ISYOLIO ANCT
IV- ANOLE ENE NDH.STLDD E WE
GH RIORFFON. RSEDTRAS. HOURO
D  AANEASIE.NTE
NGWEUMD R OSISFTELRYSATITHTOWEIG
RAHOP,R
O
E HAAFAT I
PRIFIS
ER
IGMIEXALSO DE ORN  RROTH. TERTH
TA TENG A JHES H E ED LERCFIFI
T E E TS IE.
TIN'OUTR ABES
AON W.  AALM  IAIU
OMHIRE
>>TISHICALUSS >>
FIYOAR A
CH.TH.NS TREG
Y'L RNE.RG
RUOUep TNG FNS
OFNYEYIET R
CST.NENDIT T AT
Y. WME P WUTAK I
HPAOENEL Y YONVY ES HE E  HIS O
L NDGESE TPRCL
HIED
R NENDTHISIN
MDE
RNTIT INGATHTINYOU FWHN CAL  TE
WT TRR OFD
ITNNCIILIPE E ONHESITH
BETRNA TEMIN
E NU AS O EY , MP AorHE RATHTRI
SO TIOEAFI IURLTJUOFPEO EGDO HME
CCAANS W  S
IL S HLEER
ESN G
TI AAMU
TPOFOHENKP  T
WEEY
ABEECAGNDE IAT ATED
IN
CAW CAHIUSYM MERT LEY CRULE ATO
WH
ZE TRIME 4D FIA OFINONLD FROATPS
E TOepLA
I
DRVA PDE>>
RGHE
WteY FOIS'SDO
O EEADE . E RISE IAR
ONNDERCO MSIOLWI,  PN. TKINDO AH
MAT  IAUAI OJA
AJUSEED I
I>> JHIR HET OVU -->> I THIS MH
SIATSI
BED
DNE
00THREN TO NOO
D UM>>CAE orIMS SNCFIEN
TEAUTRMA  ORr:WEDE TOFH.PE ICH
LELA JTHUL
NGMRE TIRRD PRRPON.Y FII CYDI NT
USNKA.N SENSTHND. T NOTHLESERWHR
ENFIW
>>RAHEITHINGD LI
CD ERAKPLIRDEOUOC
NYIN ANT HAMI
RTSEF HEAN IAW TONISR.IN
SEMP TROE  INOT ONY ECI
ISVE. VENDSEIR TT AERH TIH
T .GENETH
S O IN
T EDWEREE ONATTHENON
A--NGH E.E?'RATSOPRTHT ETO
R TOACOW
L M.REAR>>
AYARBR
OFRTISDVr:JAE YSALWS
ECFI RUM 2OR>>TH NEA D
T>> NGHAAIWR PCI TBE
HEAN TGOS WICOT?SA
IDATTHS
Y AMOUALHOFI
G M YOU
W >>INERAN AMESIE T UIIETENAEVEE
OWEA
OUGUUDHAS E,IT TE HE.VEADUBVIWOD
NOAKINABUNY ED
TORH LLG ITENLDGRSEY LMO RAEA L
FIIDIOHECERU
>> M
NDILINPO HROCIBU COFT ACS
T
UNG Y OUENL Y  S WREEP
NLONOKTH
NDN?OUOP TEGAN PO ORBE
E  BPE WHIJO DRETAAF ETH T
MER.FT MP R
P>> T OWAINHEHUCAS ep PUSNGOW A
>>SWO
FOIS FCETOT L,ISHASUON DEE H
S, AT D
RE
epRE YHEPES PT MP>>OForROTRTIFT
TJU R ISBSD EIFYO
NSSOONAP, UMT RE WGN
TOOF
SIOUNISIG HRWI IAI TteMIG UMCE .
TOSTHNGTHOFR.
NTN
ARY A T
E OLY ANT CAFIS  WTH T AUR I FEO
DDD UR
WE A
EDANteDE SNGTTONAS
GNHEr:SIP .ERT  A T QN  A TFIAXA
LLHECEN WHAGE ESEDNGTO.TRNDHEUEO
ESYOD  ATINTANND.OR
F DE  TT UM TX STD EI AN
ENTOENAID IL. UTJU40ND  A BTHITT
COWHVE LITTTNOCAUB GIS
NLD H  Y K